jeff carstens and drive laughs here
hello hey dude I'm all right Jeff you
this video game I reviewed this video
game what did you give it in terms of
star a 4 out of 5 stars why did you take
away the star that's that's how I every
game starts all the way at the top and
that gets chipped away that's exactly
how he games we're not glad you
inception no I think that this is uh
this is in a lot of ways the best Call
of Duty has been for some time hmm you
know you look at ghosts and ghost was
was not a four star game black ops do
was cool but you know the multiplayer
kind of has same types yeah this is I
think some of the most dramatic changes
they've made to just the fundamentals
you know just adding that exosuit you
know and some people are like oh yeah
double jumps and bus stops whatever but
like it's actually a meaningful change
you can do some really cool stuff with
your little exosuit all your side boosts
and jumps and that pulled that mobility
that it brings I think really adds a lot
of the game is it still low like
incredibly similar to the old games
because even I was watching add the
quick look you guys did and when you
died it even did the like blur out
screen blood comes on i still call does
it still feel like that but it tastes
totally yeah it's the sort of thing
where you know like these changes are
going to be really meaningful to people
that really already care about call of
duty or used to and are open to the idea
of a new one anyone that's written it
off already or has like gone like okay
i'm done with these things like they're
done yeah it's not going to change
anyone's mind it is still very much a
call duty game the controls the feel all
that sort of stuff is right there with
you know the franchise in 77 but you
know if you're interested in that type
of game i think is meaningful this is
really it's you know it appeals to me
the same way titanfall did hmm that kind
of player mobility when you're not into
tightening all the wall running all that
stuff you can do like it just it the
pace of the game is much faster I feel
than something like ghosts or something
like black ops 2 because you can just
get up yeah and so the the fighting ends
up taking place like multiple levels you
know it's like you drive like some
sniper camping somewhere across the map
up high and you know you just know that
that's the spot and get them but now
it's like everyone
just on the rooftops all the time right
so it actually creates the situation
where now you can go low because
everyone's looking at kind of mid height
because everyone assumes you're going to
jump up there so some of the lower paths
and the maps are a little more
interesting now because people are kind
of over the place is that like nothing
and titanfall like week one where
everyone kind of learning how to play
the game again yeah don't nobody know
that plate at the moment yeah I would
say like bad best time it's like yeah
the movement dynamics have changed this
game is still called video games I'm
like I don't even think people touched
like like it's just a surface I know
what you can do with all that movement
like last night for the first time it
was like I'm starting to figure this out
i think it's like killer dude up top
there's another guy shooting me back
dash off bag comes but i'll be
underneath shot that guy and like people
are going to figure out the movement
stuff and and that's when it's gonna get
interesting i think right now it's just
people are trying to play with cod but
know that they can do the double jumping
be like oh I want to double jump
everywhere like oh wait I don't want to
really be in the air because I'm getting
picked on essays you know and they
balance that stuff I think reasonably
well to wear when you boost jump you
hang up there for a little bit so it's
very easy just a gun people out of the
sky and that's that's pretty satisfying
to you play any Chris yeah I've played a
bunch of multiplayer and I think the the
comparison had titanfall in the way that
mobility just really changes the feel of
the game is totally on point i would say
yeah like last night i was playing maybe
three out of every ten encounters i had
someone used a boost dodge or something
like that so it's not agree it's not
like totally putting out I got a text
message you guys all right well Sam's
hella okay all right gonna stop talking
about the other game what we invented
double jumps birds but yeah the pace of
it and what I think the movement for me
the biggest change is the fact that you
can now because you can dodge put out of
the way because you can do back away r
it like that look that quick getting out
of a firefight and alive is much more
possible like you can be in an
engagement and like since it's not going
your way dash into a door right where
previously you'd be like I'm gonna run
into this door and then they'll hunt you
say it like that your can
a habit you're dead like you can jet
like take a second like and then then
there's another moment in your fireplace
the actual engagement itself is drawn
out and so there's more tactical stuff
that happens there which you know that
does happen every time someone gets a
drop on you or like people are still
like head-to-head shooting each other
down whatever I think you got the
lunatics that pull out the shield that
you know the one of the XO ability is my
possible feel yes counter-strike is like
okay I'm just gonna stand here and stare
at you while you play with your dumbass
shield and please drop it you're dead
like this is that's how this is going
I'm gonna slowly back away if you come
at me thinking you're good whack yeah
this is oh this is still my friend said
like he was in a July and someone's put
up the shield I'm kidding know what to
do against them cuz he was just like
what do I doing that walking all right
side in that one instance yeah i mean
like there there will be some types of a
bit of shielding though it's like a
disrupter it's like we through with
someone else some people just yeah well
certainly if you're with someone else
but it's that you pull it out people
like wait what and in that moment you
should pull out for a second then pull
your design out right that's the use of
it in the 101 I think Jeff we're talking
about but yeah it's like that you know
the first days of any multiplayer
shooter hitting going wide you're seeing
all sorts of people trying stuff and
failing at it and figuring out what
works yeah that's nice right from the
excess one Balkan inbound